[Poods]: Hey how's it goin' bros!
[Poods]: My name is Peeewdiepie!!
[Poods]: Why are we sitting on the floor of my studio?
[Marzia]: And I'm Marzia!.....
[Both]: *chuckles*
[Poods]: Oh hey! Mar-Marzia is here I guess...
[Marzia]: I'm here yeah
[Poods]: We got foot cam goin on!!
[Marzia]: OH MAH GOD
[Marzia]: You are without socks!
[Poods]: That- Why am I without socks?
[Poods]: What a great question, Marzia, to ask!
[Poods]: BECAUSE
[Marzia]: I didn't ask that quest- *chuckles*
[Poods]: That's what you asked... because
[Poods]: I GOT MY OWN SOOOOOCKS!
[Marzia]: "Happy Socks"
[Poods]: So Happy Socks is a brand from Sweden,
[Poods]: They make really cool socks,
[Poods]: They asked if wanted to make some & I'm like hell yeah!
[Marzia]: *nods* mm hmm..
[Poods:] HAAL YAAH!!! IT'S CHRISTMAS!!
[Poods]: This is an excellent gift to anyone who is a bro!
[Poods]: Or if you are - uh have a friend who is a bro,
[Poods]: Give 'em some socks and be like
[Poods]: "HEY!"
[Poods]: "You got ugly feet..."
[Poods]: "Put these on!"
[Marzia]: Also it's cold...
[Poods]: ALSOO IT IS COLD.
[Poods]: Arright I'm gonna unbox for the foot cam,
[Poods]: So it looks better.
[Marzia]: I like the packaging.
[Poods]: I-I've designed it myself!!
[Poods]: FINALLY! I have some merch to be excited about...
[Marzia]: Woooooooooow...
[Poods]: Pa ra baaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaam!
[Poods]: I'm gonna guess you go for the pug ones.
[Marzia]: Yep.
[Poods]: Yeah.
[Marzia]: For sure!
[Poods]: I'm gonna go for the brofist ones...
[Poods]: I like these because they're nice... *chuckles*
[Poods]: I like these because of the tip... ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
[Poods]: Like it looks cool...
[Poods]: WHAT IS THIS?!
[Poods]: TAKE THIS STUPID SOCKS AWAY!!
[Marzia]: PEOPLE ARE WEIRDOS ONLINE!!
[Marzia]: *chuckles*
[Poods]: Keep your feet away from me ok?
[Poods]: This is not why we're doing this...
[Poods]: OM MAH GOD
[Poods]: You saw my butt...
[Poods]: Y- This is a butt cam!
[Marzia]: Yeah...
[Marzia]: Hahahaha!
[Poods]: Stop! N-hahaha!
[Poods]: This is cool,
[Poods]: I like them.
[Poods]: They're very cool.
[Poods]: First challenge is that we're gonna draw with our feet.
[Poods]: Lemme adjust-
[Marzia]: What do we draw?
*DING DING DING*
[Poods]: Ok, so we have to draw each other,
[Poods]: the best way possible with our feet.
[Poods]: Man, you are gonna look so good Marzia.
[Poods]: You're such a beautiful Italian.
[Poods]: Italian beautiful goddess.
[Marzia]: Thank you.
[Poods]: Alright, yeah you're welcome.
[Poods]: WHAT IS THAT?!
[Poods]: Stop y-y-y-you.
[Poods]: That looks like a potato,
[Poods]: That looks like a testicle.
[Marzia]: I got your nose, ALRIGHT.
[Poods]: SHUT.. UP..
[Poods]: Can you believe her?
[Poods]: "I got your nose right."
[Poods]: OKAY
[Marzia}: It's a pretty good masterpiece.
[Marzia]: I think I got you- [Poods]: WhAt tHe hELL is THiS?
[Poods]: Oh you got my nose right, you got my nose right.
[Poods]: Look at your eyebrows,
[Poods]: They're matching hundred percent. [Marzia]: On fleek! [Poods]: On fleek.
[Poods]: Yeah, this is terrible. *claps*
[Marzia]: Who won? [Poods]: I won.
*DING DING DING*
[Poods]: There's an arm wrestling game you have
[Poods]: to press as fast as possible
[Marzia]: This is not fair cause you're gonna-.
[Poods]: *mocking Marzia* "This is not fair because I won't win!"
[Poods]: Ok here we go. You ready? [Marzia]: Yeah.
[Game]: 3, 2, 1, GOOOO!
*intense grunting*
[Poods]: It's not working.
[Poods]: YOU TURNED IT OFF!!! [Marzia]: I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING!
*intense music*
[Game]: GOOO!
[Poods]: Oh, oh, OH, OHHH.
[Poods]: You're really bad at this.
*DING DING DING*
[Poods]: Alright, so the challenge is, we have two fruits. I will open the banana and you will open the clementine with your feet!
[Poods]: 3, 2, 1.
[Both]: *laughing* [Poods]: Ok, come on. No cheating.
[Poods]: Oh wow. Oh, oh-h, oh.
[Poods]: AHH, I GOT A CRAMP.
[Poods]: I got a cramp in my foot ow.
[Poods]: Ew, what are you doing?
*laughing*
[Poods]: What is wrong with you?
[Marzia]: You told me to open it and I did!
[Marzia]: I won... How do you open a clementine?
[Poods]: Fine, alright fine.
*DING DING DING*
[Marzia]: It's the last challenge- [Poods]: Hold on, for this one, I gotta change my socks.
[Poods]: I really like these ones... They're very cool.
[Poods]: They're very spunky, psychedelic.
[Poods]: A fighting game!
[Marzia]: Hmm. [Poods]: Oh my god, so you're on the left. I'm on the right. Ladies and gentlemen, it's a show!
[Poods]: Oh my god, this is so hard. *foot cam* [Poods]: Oh, oh.
[Poods]: This is actually working? What the hell?
[Marzia]: Y-you can't use your hands. Move! [Poods]: Ok, ok, ok, ok. I'm moving them.
[Poods]: Come on. This is so weird! I'm trying to use combos.
[Poods]: And advanced moves.
[Poods]: No! I'm dead.
[Marzia]: *laughing* [Poods]: How, how, how?
[Poods]: Look at my new character though. Mm-mm-mm.
[Poods]: In the corner. [Marzia]: Mary Poppins? [Poods]: Dammit.
[Poods]: YEAH YOU GOT A PROBLEM WITH MARY POPPINS?!
[Poods]: WHAT IS HAPPENING? There's too-o-o much. I don't.
[Poods]: Oh yeah, I'm the blonde one now. It's the best.
[Poods]: Look at me.
[Poods]: I'm so cool. [Marzia]: Woah.
[Poods]: Hey. Oh! Oh! NO!
[Poods]: YOU WAITED FOR THAT OH.
[Poods]: I'M LOSING MY CONTROLLER.
[Poods]: It's going away! [Marzia]: What are you doing??
[Poods]: YEAHHH!
[Poods]: Ok, what a great game. Wow. Okay great wow. [Marzia]: Did I win?
[Poods]: No, no one won- [Marzia]: Who won? [Poods]: Cause you suck.
[Marzia]: Who won..? [Poods]: Doesn't matter.
[Poods]: I'm goin'. [Marzia]: What do we do? [Poods]: I'm goin'.
[Poods]: You press "x" and "y". Oh my god I'm doing really well.. [Poods]: How am I good- doing so good?
[Poods]: Oh! Saladass!
[Poods]: Oh that's you! No! Noo!
[Poods]: Stop. No, no!
[Poods]: How am- No! No, no. Stay. Sto-o-op. No. No-o-o
[Poods]: No-o! NOO!
[Poods]: Come on Saladass! Come on!
*intense grunting and screaming*
[Poods]: Oh! OH! YESSSSSS! *laughing* Oh-h. Yes.
[Poods]: Oh my god. [Marzia]: Well then.
[Poods]: Hey, foot five.
[Poods]: Ow.
[Marzia]: And I..
*laughing*
[Poods]: You're pushing me out! [Marzia]: *laughing* [Poods]: Stop! Stop.
[Poods]: The hell.
*screaming and laughing*
*Poods brings Slippy*
[Marzia]: Hold him. Hold him.
[Poods]: I am! [Marzia]: *screams* [Poods]: I am, I am, I am.
[Poods]: He's nice. [Marzia]: I know but I'm scared.
[Poods]: Yeah. Hey Slippy. Hey.
[Poods]: Isn't he cute? [Marzia]: He's very cute but I'm afraid that he's gonna  jump on me and attack me.
[Poods]: Well this design of this sock was inspired by Slippy, so this should be your socks Slippy.
[Slippy]: Thank you I appreciate that, that's very kind of you.
[Slippy]: Oh, thanks guys for supporting PewDiePie's socks. I would wear them but I can't.
[Poods]: Bye Slippy.
[Poods]: Well, well, well.
[Poods]: Thank you for doing the foot- the foot challenge! [Marzia]: Yeahh! [Poods]: Yeah.
[Poods]: Clap it up everyone, clap it up.
[Poods]: So yeah, check out "Happy Socks", I'm really proud and happy to be working with them.
[Poods]: It's a really cool brand and I think you guys will like it. [Marzia]: Mhm.
[Poods]: Leave a like if you enjoyed this video and as always...
[Poods]: BROFIST!
[Marzia]: Foot fist?
[Poods]: Yeah, you have to come closer though.
[Marzia]: *explosion noises*
*Music*
*Music starts fading outs slowly*